a new warning from the fda about some
coronavirus vaccines due to a rare
possible side effect
there have now been almost 400 confirmed
cases of heart inflammation
among people 30 or younger after they
received either the moderna or pfizer
vaccines experts are still strongly
recommending vaccinations for everyone
12 and up
because the complications from kovid can
be much more severe
nikki batista is outside mount sinai
west hospital in new york nikki what
should families
know about this tarika good morning
well despite this warning from the cdc
and fda the cases of heart inflammation
are rare data suggests just about 12
cases
per million vaccinations in young people
but
one family we spoke with says it's still
important to
watch for symptoms when we pulled into
the emergency room i was
just praying because he was in such a
bad state
noah hires went to the hospital just
days after a second pfizer dose
i woke up at 2 am with chest pain
the 16 year old said symptoms kept
coming and going before he was admitted
with suspected myocarditis
a type of heart inflammation that a cdc
advisory panel linked with coveted
vaccines
tracking more than 1200 cases most were
linked to pfizer
occurred after the second dose and were
mainly in males
24 or younger symptoms include chest
pains
heart palpitations and shortness of
breath still the cdc is urging
everyone to get vaccinated because risk
from the coronavirus is greater and as
the delta variant
continues to drive cases kids could be
especially susceptible
there is a large group that is still
unvaccinated and they are going to
continue to be at risk
of disease of severe disease of
getting long covet and all of those
problems that come with it
this experience was much better than
getting coveted noah was in the hospital
for about one day and said he's felt no
symptoms since leaving i would say
please please please
get the vaccine and let's put all this
behind us
noah's mom opted to have her younger son
who is 14
also get a vaccine even after noah's
experience
and again those heart conditions are
rare and if they do occur
are usually temporary and in most cases
mild
tony nikki thank you very much